Mutual authentication
protocol takes five steps.
Can we simplify it?
That is, can we use fewer steps?
It seems that the following would work.
First, Alice says hi to Bob and
sends along a challenge R2.
Second, in response,
Bob sends Alice the ciphertext of R2,
and his own challenge R1.
Upon receiving this response,
Alice decrypts the ciphertext
to see if it matches the plain text,
R2, that she has sent to Bob.
If it matches, then she knows that
she's communicating with Bob.
Third, Alice then sends
Bob the ciphertext of R1.
And Bob decrypts it and
matches it with the plain text, R1,
to authenticate Alice.
Is there anything wrong with
this simplified protocol?
It turns out that there
is a reflection attack,
a kind of man in the middle attacks.
Here's how it works.
First, Trudy impersonates Alice.
By following the protocol,
Trudy will be stuck at step three
because she can not encrypt
the challenge, R1, sent from Bob.
She does not have the key KAB.
Then Trudy simply opens another
connection with Bob and, again,
impersonating Alice.
This time Trudy sends Bob the challenge,
R1,
that Bob has sent her in the first
connection, the one that she stuck in.
According to the protocol,
Bob responds with a ciphertext of R1 and
another challenge, R3.
Notice that Bob has send
the ciphertext of R1 to Alice.
So what Trudy can do is to
take this ciphertext of R1.
Then Trudy can now go back to the step
three of the first connection and
send it back to Bob to
complete the first connection.
That is, at this point, the first
connection successfully concludes, and
Trudy has successfully
impersonated Alice.
This is called a reflection
attack because Trudy simply
sends back to Bob what Bob had just
sent her from another connection.
So how can we prevent
reflection attacks?
One way is to use two
different share keys.
One is for the initiator of
the connection, say Alice, and
the other is for the responder, say Bob.
The result is that the ciphertext
that Trudy gets from Bob can not be
presented as a ciphertext from
Alice because these two ciphertexts
should be using two different keys.
That is,
there are two share keys being used.
Say Alice used KAB1 and Bob used KAB2.
Therefore the ciphertext from
Bob is encrypted using KAB2,
and Bob is going to expect
a ciphertext using KAB1.
Therefore, even though Trudy
can accept the ciphertext, but
this Cipher text is produced using KAB2.
She cannot simply send
it back to Bob because
the ciphertext sent to Bob
must be encrypted using KAB1.
Another way to prevent
the reflection attack
is to use different challenges for
the initiator and the responder.
For example, we can use an even
number challenge for Alice and
odd number for Bob.
Therefore, when Trudy
receives a challenge, R1,
from Bob the challenge is an odd number,
and Trudy cannot use.
This is a new challenge for Bob because
Bob is expecting an even number.